The evolution of technology
has influenced the way we
create music.
Computers are smarter than
they've ever been before, and
they have become essential to
modern music production and
live performance.
But where do we go from here?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm a research fellow looking
at synchronisation in live
performance.
This is how you might get
technology to respond and
listen to live musicians
as they play.
But in order to do that,
we need to teach
the computer to listen.
Some bands might want technology
to play an
important part in their live
show, for instance the samples
and sequences that are there
in the studio are playing.
And in order to do that commonly
at the moment, they
use a backing track.
And that generally involves
a drummer listening to a
metronome click that's
in his ears.
And effectively you're then a
slave to that technology.
You're following a fixed
metronomic pace.
And the music isn't really
live in the sense that we
know, if you think of old bands
like Led Zeppelin or the
Rolling Stones.
So I started doing research here
at the Centre of Digital
Music Queen Mary University in
London, in a system that would
follow the drums, basically.
On the basis that the drums
are central to a
rock and roll band.
And that's probably what
the musicians follow.
So if we get the system to
follow the drummer, you're
sort of replacing that click
track, essentially.
The click track that used to
maybe have to be listened to
by the drummer, that would
listen to him instead, and
follow him.
Sound travels in waves, rather
like the ripples in a stream.
And the distance between the
peaks of those waves is the
wavelength.
That determines the pitch
that we hear.
So if we want to change the
speed of sound, ordinarily you
might just play it faster.
But that will change the pitch,
like on a record player.
Instead we use something called
time stretching, where
we chop the sound into grains,
like this ball.
And then if we want this piece
of sound to be shorter, we'll
just remove some
of the grains.
And it will go faster,
but each of
them at the same pitch.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well I've effectively got the
sequencer running, which is
the backing music.
And the click track
gets fed in.
So you're monitoring both the
drums coming in and it's own
internal click.
And I'm also looking a bit at
how it handles these patterns.
Because he's an interesting
drummer to have play.
He's not just doing a very basic
beat, more of a funky
kind of syncopated thing than
just, say, a straight rhythm.
I think that's why it's an
interesting test case to get
this to look at it.
Dave the drummer is
the one running.
And that's me on the bike,
represents the click track.
He can't speed up or slow down
because he has to stay
in time with me.
If the drummer does speed up
or slow down, he won't stay
with the steady click
track, and the sound
will be out of sync.
What my software does is allow
Dave the drummer to go as fast
or slow as he likes.
By time stretching, the
click track will stay
in time with him.
In the studio, I'm testing how
well my software can keep up
with a real drummer.
So I've asked him to try
changing tempo to see how well
he thinks the click track
keeps up with him.
Part of the problem
is he's too good.
Drummers are so well trained to
adhere to click tracks that
being in charge one, instead of
it being in charge of you
is a very alien concept.
I think what's interesting
about this is it could
eliminate the drummer having to
be a slave to a click track
in his ear.
The drummer can kind of keep
a steady-ish tempo.
This system will be able
to follow what
the drummer is doing.
I think in terms of results it's
interesting to hear Matt
talk about technology.
It's not something he's used
to, really, a backing track
that moves.
I suppose beyond this, you'd
want to go and see how it
works in a band, in a live
setting, and see what creative
uses do people want
to put it to.
Can they create a hybrid kind
of music, where you've got
live musicians and some other
more sample or computer-based
stuff going on?
Well the system isn't yet
perfect, and there's still
work to do.
But for now, I'm happy.
If you're interested to know
more about my research or want
to try out this software, feel
free to contact me, Andrew
Robertson, at Queen Mary
University of London.
You can also visit
the website.
That's b-keeper.org.
[DRUMS PLAYING]